the number for you Brady I'm loving this
number number is is great it's so cool
on four to eight five seven I want you
to M just give me a number good name
okay fine then I'm going to multiply
this by thirteen okay okay I can't do
that me Ed
so let's now I take the last six not the
six numbers e right I'm going to take
the last six of these and add it to the
pair's one that's one plus eight five
seven one four one now I can do that
that is eight five seven one four two
which if you look carefully is a
permutation of this case it's one four
two eight five seven I mean all the
number really give it on the number 112
right 112 very good so one four two
eight five seven times 112 equals right
let's do it
okay I noticed something about 112
you're paying for choosing hundred
twelve but we see something else okay
112 I think must be a multiple of seven
and five to tease all right zoom ruined
it with it what was the sound of the
early ones if they do something else to
do service life specially is Rama day
let's run with it okay
multiples of seven double do it take the
last six okay fifteen plus nine nine
nine nine eight four equals nine nine
nine nine nine no okay give it will do
one more okay
eighteen eighteen okay not on multiple
seven thank you okay two million 571 426
do the same thing take the last six and
I get five seven one four two eight
which is one four two eight five so if I
take any anything that's not a multiple
a certain anything that's not a multiple
of seven and I multiply this number by
it and then I do this procedure of a
sort of taking the last six and adding
the previous one of the other ones I
always get a permutation of one four two
eight five seven in particular if I take
the numbers one to six the six not
ditches here and I multiply this by them
I will
always get a permutation of one57 so for
example I've seen if I multiply it by
one I get one four two eight five seven
that's trivial if I multiply it by 2 I
get two eight five seven one four which
again it's a permutation multiplied by
three I get four two eight five seven
one and so on and so forth and I can
keep doing this and if you go above
seven when if you go above seven then
you need to do this business of sort of
taking the last six and then adding it
but you'll always get this this this
cyclic structure this is an example of a
cyclic number in fact a column right not
particularly
okay so this is the only one that
doesn't begin in zero the next one
actually after this one is O five eight
eight two three five two nine four one
one seven six four seven this is another
cyclic number okay this has got 16
digits you play the same game you can
take in this now you would multiply it
between what's important is the fact
it's got 16 digits so if you do
multiples of 17 this goes wrong but if
you do one two 16 you'll get a
permutation of it and then you can play
this game as well but with 16 rows and
six digits so here's the other weird
thing about it if you multiply it by any
multiple of seven you always get these
all the nines if I multiply this guy
this has got sep this has got 16 digits
if I multiply this by 17 I'll get all
the nines why does it work okay let's
see why it works I'm going to need more
paper
okay well the important thing about that
number that one one four two eight five
seven is it appears in the
decimalisation of a seventh okay if I
take a seventh right then a seventh is
equal to naught point one four two eight
five seven one four two eight five seven
two delidio and so on keeps repeating
and this is critical why is this
critical well now think what happens
when I multiply this by 10 and multiply
it by ten ten sevenths I multiply it by
ten all these numbers just
if the long one right and now but what
you know about this this is just ten
sevenths is one plus three cents right
okay so from this you can infer that 3/7
is equal to naught point four two eight
five seven one four good isn't it and
the point is as you can see that all the
multiplying by ten just shifted
everything along one okay and then we
pull off this original one but it got
replaced by another one and getting
shifted along and then you're left with
a permutation it works perfectly and it
keeps working now we can do the next one
see and multiply it by 10 again so do
multiply by ten do thirty seventh and I
get again I just shift everything just
get shifted along by one but this I know
is four plus two sevenths so I get rid
of the fours and I conclude that two
sevenths it's just naught point two
eight five seven one four and again it
was just everything got shifted by one
but because it was the stuff that you
removed that replaces it you just end up
with permutations and that's why it
works that's essentially the essence of
why it works and actually from this
structure you can see why and what the
structure of all these cyclic numbers
has to be so you take a prime number you
take its reciprocal 1 over a prime okay
it doesn't work for all prime numbers
with some prime numbers it does actually
we'll come back to that in a minute but
you'll get something naught times some
your cyclic number and your psychic norm
it gets repeated okay this is a P minus
1 the number of length P minus 1 so here
it was 1/7 and these are these this
blocks are the length of 6 ok so if I
multiply this by 10 to the power P minus
1 in this case by 10 to the 6 I get 10
to the P minus 1 over P is equal to well
my cyclic number point my cyclic number
so you got all the second you get the
same thing now
take these two away from one another and
you conclude that your cyclic number is
equal to 10 to the P minus 1 minus 1
over P and this is where those nines
appear ok so I multiply this by P the
prime number which in this case was 7 or
any multiple of 7 I get something that's
related to the 9th right because it's 10
to the some power minus 1 which is going
to be all the 9th right so that's why it
works all the cyclic numbers have this
form not all prime numbers will give a
cyclic number when you construct this
guy so the prime numbers that work that
give you if you construct this that will
give you a cyclic number RP equals 7 7
17 19 23 29 the first few more ok
they're an infinite number there are an
infinite number yes and in fact and this
is this is one of these things that I
just think number theorist heartily they
dream up these things we even know how
many what percentage of prime numbers
give cyclic numbers when you can start
this it's thirty seven point three nine
five percent roughly their prime numbers
will give cyclic numbers in this way by
why we saw how if we multiply it by
multiples of seven and then we do our
little construction that we've discussed
that we get back all the nines okay all
the nines appears everywhere in this
what else can you do let's look at it
one four two eight five seven okay let
me take the first two numbers let me
take the next two 28 I take next one
57th I'll add them all together look
what I get have some of that
all the lines right let me do this let
me take 3 1 4 2 plus 8 5 7 add them
together what do I get
oh no no hey let me even do this let me
do four right I get 1 4 2 8 plus 5 7 1 4
I have to use everywhere not with the
same number of times
2 8 5 7 what's that 9
no no
a summation is amazing this is not it
why it's going on it's all related of
course to this very special property
then it's basically these numbers can be
written as tensor some power minus one
divided by the by the prime number but
it's clearly just there you know it's
almost in there and they all have this
property they'll all do this and you can
also work in different bases you know
you can have cyclic numbers in different
bases what happens then is the cyclic
numbers instead of being with we're
working in base 10 is we're familiar
with but you just change this number
from 10 and then you get the cyclic
numbers again I can you can play the
same games and they list but there cause
they're cyclic in that particular base
and there instead of getting all the
nines you might get all the threes or
all the fours depending on whatever base
you're in it's amazing though it doesn't
even stop there there's one more
quirkiness that I've gotta show you on
four to eight five seven okay
now we're going to take the first three
numbers one for two and then square it
to eight five seven squared what do we
get seven one four two eight five what's
that
it's another permutation of our one four
two eight five seven it's amazing and
this number actually it's it were not
the only people to notice that this
number has a little quirky qualities
there's something called an Enneagram
now this is some crazy Armenian
spiritual leader from like wartime
called Gurdjieff and there he basically
was able to explain everything in life
and the cosmos through this number tell
Lots it's the last said the better but
he did draw a nice pretty picture which
I think we can draw which sort of just
gives us our last little thing to do
with this this nice number so here we go
I draw that is a rubbish circle but
we'll do we just draw nine there 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 ok so we're going to multiples
of 3 we're not just then boring get rid
of them not that any numbers are boring
obviously but and we just draw a
triangle okay now the remaining numbers
we just sort of draw this nice pretty
picture through them 1 2 4 2 2 2 8
to five to seven and then back to one
again and this is called an Enneagram
and apparently the properties of this
can be related to cells and all sorts
but less said about the better but it's
a nice picture isn't it so one four two
eight five seven cycle them amazing I
love it